Bob Nightingale USA Today baseball
columnist the most recent column is
Bryce Harper will sign with the Phillies
you can bank on it
Bob good morning your how solid is this
this story here you know you were
meeting is dead and you survey all these
executives everybody's saying it's got
to be the Philadelphia Phillies I mean
it used to be the Nationals but even
blink when they offered 300 million
dollars there was no counteroffer or
whatsoever say you know thank you so
much I think it worked at least 400
million dollars and the Phillies are
begging someone to take their money
Damon shadows should end up with the
Yankees millions Harper with the
Phillies at Harper likes Philadelphia as
a launching pad for the hitters so he
can put up some Hall of Fame numbers for
sure I love you
is it going to be 400 million dollars
but I think I think it starts with
before I really do I think it's going to
get at least a 12 year contract if not
13 year contract is he worth it you know
who knows who's worth what but yet
probably is you know at that age
if he can you know I know Scott Boras
yesterday was saying you know we started
studying with the Nationals you know in
2010 the franchise has worked for her
million now it's worth in excess of two
billion dollars so I do think I'll put
people in the seats I do think the it
will watch more Phillies games you know
you can start winning some of my
championships there you know why not you
see a hall-of-famer
I mean yeah Hall of Fame peace
she'll never chance you know uh you know
practice got Boras he was talking about
you know he's the only guy since 2010 to
have 1100 old PS one year you know the
last guy to do that where's George Brett
if you roll out the TV era so he
certainly has a chance to be a holic
alien for sure yeah but okay what if
Mike Trout with two years left and then
you can all of a sudden go get a Philly
guy New Jersey guy who's a Philly fan
you know but could you wait is there any
chance
you could get Mike Trout you know know
the abilities you know will love to get
my trout there how does a huge Eagles
fan and everything else your home Super
Bowl trophy I think Mike Trout is very
comfortable in Anaheim I really do you
know when the season's over he goes
right back you know right back to Jersey
and everything else but I think he kind
of like school on the radar lack of
attention lack of bright lights
everything else and I don't think
there's any way in the world that the
Angels will let him walk away before
2020 they're not going to trade him you
know I think they'll love put a huge
contract in front of them I think the
best thing for my truck is what's going
to happen with Bryce Harper here and
Manny Machado where he can piggyback off
those contracts maybe even get more I
you think it's a foregone conclusion
Manny Machado ends up with the Yankees
Miami you know die-hard Yankee fan Alex
Rodriguez was his mentor he loves him
all he ever talked about his friends is
being a Yankee that he's a perfect fit
for him too I think with the leadership
it there they have and everything else
he doesn't have to be the guy I think it
being absolutely studded Yankee Stadium
what positions he's gonna play yeah
great question I think he's got to be a
third base I think those are at
shortstop and so these are glorious
comes back
MPD's give me a free agent after
nineteen anyway but Italy you can slide
them over to third base you know move on
to Hunter to the outfield you'll do what
you want but this guy's you know a girl
well third baseman
I mean even Brooks Robinson watch them
all those years in Baltimore because you
know what he's a better third baseman
than I am if it's not Philadelphia for
Bryce Harper who would it be
maybe Sam Sisko Giants but the aside you
know this hide a new GM bar hands IET if
you're hired a new GM with a little back
rub you know it seems like you've got to
change course there so I think they kind
of do restructure that won't seem in
everything else I don't see another
national fit for Harper III really don't
Cubs are gonna go to the luxury tax yo
Dodgers you know they don't spend that
kind of money so I just don't see a
natural fit unless for some reason to
Washington national and say okay you
want to take 300 million will you take
400 million that's your energy
I saw the only time she had a report
that the Dodgers tried to trade yasiel
Puig for Bryce Harper like you can't do
that straight-up like what what else you
know like what else was gonna be in that
deal if Walker Buehler is not in the
deal then I'm not even listening but you
know you're gonna try to get Bryce
Harper yeah that's not happening admits
had to trade play before they had talks
with the Milwaukee Brewers remember one
time for a Ryan Braun in bat and it
worked out of the world are you gonna
get a belt like Harper so I did I just
always throw a lot of stuff out there
you know just in case someone man when
you've been drinking too much late at
night speaking of which I'll see you
over the weekend yeah looking forward to
there's a fun time yeah yeah cross pass
thank you Bob again and talk to you soon
Bob Nightingale for more Dan Patrick
show to the audience channel 239 on
DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick show
app
[Music]